mr. Andy Baumann hey Rob handle what's
up i dude we are looking at Far Cry
primal and I for one am NOT a huge
advocate of the owl which is a companion
you can have that can do many things but
you sir have gone all out with it
yeah dude the owl is actually it so it
controls well way better than I expected
it's awesome for spotting things but did
you know it can actually dive bomb and
kill people they also drop bomb speaking
of bomb drop D bombs and cos art bombs
and fire bombs it's got those but most
importantly you can upgrade it to
straight-up merc your enemies basically
so it's rad i love it
let's check it out on a base takeover
sounds good to me alright look let's
call the AL there we go
boom now just kind of make a few laps
and you can like run the owl into rocks
so we got a response but for the most
part you just fly unlimited amount of
time you can't go like too far it'll
tell you hey come back you're always
gone too far
um you do have to unlock this with a
story mission right but like it's pretty
early on and so when your options is ya
go down the upgrade path of the owl
wolfy my little white white fangs gonna
kill him oh so you can command from the
sky I do that I come down just straight
up owl punch him all that you see is
feathers God that must be huge why did
you talk about that yeah the beasts got
him and that's it boom we're a hawk or
an eagle then it is yeah friggin huge
yeah and then that's it the cooldown on
the owl is pretty long um so like one of
the skills here and we love to show is
probably one of the skills here is less
cool down on your L right so the owl
attack is significantly down there 15
seconds and there's another one that
gets another 15 seconds so it's like
every 40 seconds or Alec can just be in
the air killing people once you unlock
that so you could essentially just like
stealth kill oh and entire base with
your L will a patient enough right we'll
other enemies attack the owl not so far
I'm pretty early on in the game and the
owl is pretty much everyone's oblivious
they'll and until it's up in their face
killing them our review is gonna be up
on Monday I believe is that right that's
right all right so we're doing a live
stream Friday tune in if you if you're
interested games rock and oh I love the
al yeah absolutely and also we're going
to do a stream Tuesday where we will be
showing more of the late game stuff you
know you can upgrade a lot your weapons
and get really pimped out and the Land
of Ooo DOS great can't wait for a man
thanks cool thank you right